Where do you get patterns
for your machine knitting?
Once upon a time, there were beautiful
glossy magazines and hardbound books
written just for machine knitters.
Sadly, that's not the case any longer, but
there are options that we can use to get
beautiful knitting patterns.
Let's take a look at some of those options
and make some choices as to what method
works best for you.
First, there are vintage patterns.
There's a ton of vintage
patterns available for us to use.
The problem with these vintage patterns
are that they're written for yarn that no
longer exists.
Often they're very small sizes.
The designs are pretty dated.
The good news with these patterns is they
have some really unusual stitch patterns
and innovative techniques.
So there's a lot to be gained by at least
exploring and examining these vintage
patterns.
Can you use these patterns?
Well, of course.
You'll need to do some math to convert the
stitch gauge, and you might want to update
the styles just a little bit, but these
are definitely an option for us to use.
Another choice is to use
hand knitting patterns.
Now we've got updated styles and a wealth
of beautiful designs by modern designers.
These also come in larger sizes.
Again, though, you're going to have to
match the designer's gauge, and if you
choose not to use the yarn that the
designer used, you'll need to do some math
to convert your gauge and
your yarn to their design.
Another issue with hand knitting patterns
to keep in mind is many stitch patterns
that are designed for hand knitting
are not appropriate for our machines.
You know, think of terms
of knit and purl stitches.
So you will need to
substitute stitch patterns.
Another thing of wha, the hand knitting
patterns, the modern hand knitting
patterns.
So many of them are written to be knit
from the top down or be knit in the round.
Now on our flatbed knitting
machines, that really isn't possible.
Can you take a top down pattern and just
knit a front and a back and knit from the
bottom up or from the top down?
Either way, knit it flat
in other words, absolutely.
Again, there's some math involved.
And you'll need to match the gauge.
I'm going to throw in a little
commercial here for Knit it Now Patterns.
With our Dynamic Patterns there
is no software to install.
You don't have to do any math.
Three steps.
You choose a size, you enter your gauge
and your stitch pattern and just get
knitting.
So checkout and KnititNOW.com/patterns
for our dynamic.
Perfect Fit patterns.
And I'll talk more about
them in just a minute.
Now another way to get knitting patterns
for machine knitters is to use pencil and
paper.
You could chart your own patterns.
You know, once upon a time you could go
down to the local yarn store and someone
in the local yard store would
chart a pattern for you.
Those days are over.
I think, and many of us
don't know how to chart.
It is something that is a skill
that as a machine knitter.
You should have, you should
know the basics of charting.
If nothing else, you're not going to
sit down with a blank piece of paper and
charter a sweater for yourself, but you
might want to adjust the a sleeve length
or make a minor change to a pattern.
Knowing how to chart is really
going to help you in that area.
Speaking of charting, using
software is much more common today.
There are quite a few software packages
out there that you can use to learn how to
chart, to chart your own sweaters.
One of the issues with
any software is the cost.
You have to purchase the thing.
You have to
install the thing.
You have to maintain the thing.
You have to learn the thing.
And the learning curve on some of
these software packages is pretty big.
I don't know about you, but I'd rather
speed knitting than sitting at my computer
playing with software.
But if software and original design is in
your future, you might want to consider
some of these software packages.
The nice thing about software is you can
come up with a design that you can use
over and over, change the gauge and make
minor changes to it and have really a lot
of control over your knitting pattern.
Now, something to consider when you're
considering software is the output of that
software.
What's the written pattern
look like?
Whether you print it out on paper
or you view it on the computer.
You need to be comfortable with
how the output of that pattern is.
So something to consider when
you're shopping for software.
Another way of getting knitting patterns
for machine knitting is to use a charting
device.
Now, what's a charting device?
It's something that looks
like, well, this is one style.
They came in a lot of different styles.
Some of the charting devices are
built right into the machine.
Others are a separate device like this,
and they are a visual way of knitting.
You draw the shape of your garment piece,
whether it's a sleeve or a front or a
back.
You draw it on a piece of paper or a card.
What a specific.
Piece of paper.
And then as you knit and as you push the
carriage back and forth, that design, that
drawing advances, you follow the line and
do your increases and decreases to shape
your garment piece based on the visual
little image that you're looking at.
Now, if you're lucky enough to have a
charting device for your knitting machine
and you haven't tried it, I
really encourage you to try it.
This method is very popular
with a lot of knitters.
Okay?
I'm biased, but using Knit it Now Dynamic
Patterns is the best way to get knitting
patterns.
You don't have to match my gauge.
You can use your gauge, your
stitch pattern, any machine.
We also have a perfect fit feature so that
you can fine-tune the fit and the size of
your knitting.
The patterns have no abbreviation, so none
of that cryptic abbreviation stuff like in
the old vintage patterns.
We also include tips and tricks and
instruction right in the pattern.
Videos are embedded in many
of the patterns as well.
I invite you to go to
KnititNOW.com/patterns.
And take a look at our perfect
fit dynamic blueprints.
No matter what method you choose, I really
suggest that you pick one of the methods
and use it.
Don't spend your precious knitting time
learning software and translating vintage
patterns and doing a bunch of
math with hand knitting patterns.
Pick one method and stick with it.
You'll find you'll have much more success.
Until next time, thanks for
watching and happy knitting.